long time coaching this league for the
Nixon rockets Jeff Van Gundy back here
on the Rich Eisen show how you doing
Jeff good how's everything I am doing
just fine which is the first round
matchup that intrigues you most well I
think Boston and Milwaukee is
interesting due to injuries
I think obviously Milwaukee's the
favorite in and that matchup but Boston
is so good defensively and their young
wings of brown and Tatum have performed
admirably so I'm really looking forward
to that matchup and then staying in the
Eastern Conference how much of the
momentum that we're seeing from the
Sixers how much will that play do you
think into a second season that hardly
any of them have ever been a part of
knowing the crucible of the playoffs
Jeff how much stop do you put in the
Sixers in their momentum here well you
don't win 16 games in a row if you're
not a great team and to do it in large
part without embiid is a testament to
their additions their depth grew with
the additions of Belinelli and Ilya
Silva and so they're well positioned to
be successful but take miami lightly at
your own BS because this team has proven
year after year with Erik Spoelstra is
the coat and that they will be a
difficult out they're gonna struggle to
score on some nights but they're gonna
compete they're gonna be sound
defensively and I would not be shocked
that they went into Philly in one game
one now I know you're not a doctor you
don't play one on TV but how do you
think the Sixers should handle Joel
embiid who came out with this is Phantom
of the Opera mask during pregame
shooting last night Jeff yeah I don't
think that mask itself I don't think so
allowable I think it has to be clear if
I'm not sure I'm not sure about all the
rules and regulations over mask but I
think you know the NBA you know every
team takes their players health and and
is puts it up paramount importance but I
think Joe L&B wants to play I think he's
more of a throwback who wants to play
even at times when maybe injuries say he
shouldn't play I think he has that
desire to play I think we'll see him in
the first round Jeff Van Gundy joining
me here in the Rich Eisen show which is
your first game up which one are you
doing first game up this week we have
Golden State San Antonio on Saturday and
then Cleveland Indiana on Sunday alright
so that I mean that that Spurs warriors
series know Kawhi obviously we know that
and then curry is still missing in
action right now for Golden State
how much of a chance do you give the
Spurs in this series Jeff I think equip
themselves well I think they'll play
well and I just don't think they have
the talent speed to match up without
Kawhi Leonard so I think Golden State
got a fortuitous matchup for them I
think they got a great you know break
and I think inevitably now if curry gets
back it's going to be Houston
Golden State for the championship and I
would say Houston is the favorite right
now I think they are I think they're
hungrier they're healthier and you know
the additions they made roster wise in
the offseason have worked out
spectacularly so based on what you've
said right there
the Eastern Conference championship is
only to reserve a deck chair on the
Titanic you think well I think you know
I think Toronto will win it and I think
Toronto will equip themselves well I
think because of their location in
Canada I don't think they get nearly
enough coverage or credit they're an
outstanding team there in the top five I
think both offensively and defensively
dewayne Casey has done a masterful job
in utilizing their great depth I think
their bench is a strength I think
because of Boston's injuries and
Cleveland not being as good as they have
been in the past it opened up the door
very well but their first-round matchup
against the schizophrenic Washington
Wizards yes it's gonna be a bit
harrowing I mean if if Washington you
know somehow wins one of the first two
games I mean they're good I mean they
may not play well all the time but they
are a very talented and good basketball
team Jeff Van Gundy of the worldwide
leader in sports says the NBA playoffs
will be tipping off this very weekend as
you heard Jeff and the rest of the crew
there with Mark Jackson and Mike Breen
will be at Spurs at warriors Saturday
and then Cavs and Pacers on Sunday howdy
how do you think LeBron after the season
he just had can give me the scenario in
which he carries this team past Toronto
and makes it to the finals and maybe
even to the promised land
Jeff whoa forget the promised land if he
makes it to the finals with with this
Cavalier team with all they've endured
their seeding there does not as good or
as talented as they have been in
previous years if he's able to pull it
off and get to the finals that's one of
his greatest accomplishments it would be
it would be really an incredible job by
James and the Cavaliers so I don't think
they have a chance even a remote chance
against either Golden State or Houston
and both teams are healthy but to get
there would certainly be a crowning
achievement to a spectacular year for
James is easy your MVP of the year
I know Harden would be for me is that
just because he's the best team player
on the best team with the best record
what what's your what's your criteria
there yeah really you know it's if you
want to make it a science you know I see
probably a lot of stat breakdowns but I
listen I just think winning is important
it's B it's become it sort of been
devalued in our league losing now in
many instances is praised as much as
winning
and so I think winning matters and I
look at Houston and what they've
accomplished
I think Cardin has done a fabulous job
the one thing that I would get James a
huge leg up though if I was voting that
I think it's overlooked is he he played
in every game and I think Hardin missed
nine and so that's a that's a big
difference in terms of availability and
you know Westbrook with back-to-back
triple doubles averaging it over a
season I mean he really didn't even get
much of a mention for a team that you
know obviously that did have Carmelo and
and and Paul George on it but I mean
don't you think that this is a dangerous
team having spent the entire year
getting on the same page now they're in
the next level Oklahoma City making a
thunderous run if you will Jeff well I
think you know first of all I don't put
as much stock into the triple-double you
know if he would have averaged nine
point nine rebounds I wouldn't have said
it's any less of a year I know people
love round numbers and you know but I
think too often we instead of using our
eyes to appreciate greatness we just
look at stats and if you watch Westbrook
as much as I get to watch him it's just
it's phenomenal to watch a guy play with
energy and what he did pregame last
night before they beat up on Memphis to
talk about his teammates and and in
particular
Collison Nick Collison I thought it was
a remarkable moment for them I think
they're you know Paul George is going to
have to play great for them to beat Utah
you don't have better depth I think
there are a better defensive team but
when you have the greatness of Westbrook
and the possible greatness of fall
George you can win any series and so I
think Utah will win but if Paul George
plays great to go with Westbrook
they're gonna be a tough out couple more
it's left with Jeff Van Gundy from from
ESPN as you saw I'm sure
the Knicks have parted ways with the
Jeff hornacek firing him after a fourth
consecutive 50 loss season
in Madison Square Garden obviously that
he didn't have all four of them he had
the last two your name has been bandied
about Jeff would you be interested in a
reunion with the next things I always
stay away from you know I think it's a
it's not my place to talk about that I
always think it's in the best interest
of the teams to go about them as quietly
as possible if they want to speak that's
up to them but for me in all these
coaching things I just try to stay you
know quiet and you know let situations
occur as they may and realizing how good
a job I have right now at ESPN nad no
look I I work with tons of former
coaches and and it's always puts them in
a tough bind and I say that I asked that
question with the utmost of respect
knowing that any answer that you give
that that doesn't make it's it might
make it sound like you don't love the
job that you currently have where you
win every night quite frankly so I
understand I understand that just in a
macro sense do you how much do you miss
coaching Jeff well the beauty of or the
negative of coaching is you don't get to
separate the good from the bad you know
there's a lot of great things about
coaching the competition and camaraderie
cannot be duplicated anywhere else or
replicated so you miss that you know
tremendously the stuff I get to do with
USA basketball now has we taught me that
I've really enjoyed that part very very
much so you know certainly you you miss
all the good things about coaching what
you tend to do sometimes is when you're
away from something you forget you know
the negatives and there's negatives to
every job the strain
stress of losing you know so things of
that nature so you know I love coaching
I love what I do now no one's had it
better than me no one's been luckier
than me and basketball well what's your
relationship last one I guess with James
Dolan then with with the Knicks how
often do you chat with him
the owner of the next well first of all
I don't I don't think anybody chats with
their owner on a regular basis you know
so a former owner but I think the
misconception that of my time there was
that mr. Dolan wasn't good to work for I
look at it like this
the owners I've worked for less
Alexander and the Dolan family they they
all are you know super successful and
what they've done before you know
billionaires and you know whatever but
all you want is an owner who is
steadfast in the pursuit of winning and
will give you the resources as an
organization to do that and I was very
fortunate in both my time in New York
with the Dolan family and in Houston
with les Alexander is that they gave us
the resources necessary to win and care
deeply about winning and so I have no
idea you know what everybody else's
experiences have been with ownerships
but mine in both places I had great
experiences because both both men Jim
Dolan and les Alexander were committed
to winning jeff appreciate the call I
look forward to chatting with you
throughout the NBA playoffs thanks again
man appreciate it you got it Jeff Van
Gundy of the worldwide leader in sports
here on the Rich Eisen show Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience